hola I'm Frida Kahlo as you know from
all of my paintings I usually paint
myself such as the broken column without
hope roots if you remember my quote I
said I paint self-portraits because I am
so often alone because I am the person I
know best but today is a new day and I
want to challenge myself to paint things
that aren't so selfish no self portraits
just something simple and happy
what would you like me to paint today me
yes you see did you paint a mountain
coming up for you cool
are you ready ready wow that looks
beautiful you get the sunshine and green
grass blue sky it's like a vacation spot
right there in between those two hills
it it looks a lot like your eyebrow I
know yeah it looks like a unibrow
doesn't it Oh give me another chance let
me paint something let me prove to you I
don't have to let me paint something
else go on why don't you try a heart
coming right up
oh here's your heart Wow I didn't I
didn't expect you to draw like a real
human heart right out of my chest but
I'm pretty sure there's a unibrow on the
right-hand side of that heart you drew
another one give me one more shot to
paint all right something really simple
just draw a bird a bird
yeah okay
you know what that looks great you did a
great job Freda what a terrific bird